mais matthew comme j'ai deux mille ans
bien tassés je me rappelle l'époque non
ce qu'on tentait d'ouvrir la porte et de
laisser les enfants s'amusent et j'ai
trouvé ça va participer à notre phase
d'essai jusqu'à maintenant les réactions
cette sensation de sécurité et de
sérénité
les histoires qu'on nous rapporte sont
une vraie source d'inspiration et y est
absolument aucun danger
j'en suis sur ma chérie disons que les
souvenirs sont subjectifs
il est possible qu'il ne soit pas
entièrement fiable et ils sont souvent
émotionnel je me souviens de rien celui
de total rappelez vous ce que vous avez
vu vous avez vu le véhicule qui a frappé
le piéton je n'ai pas vu l'accident se
produire ça vous embête ils ont posé
quelques questions comment ça fonctionne
cette puce va accéder à vos en g à vos
souvenirs relatifs à l'événement suis
pas intéressé par ce que vous auriez pu
faire dans votre chambre sur votre temps
libre
ce qui est privé doit rester privé
[Musique]